In Syria, US President Donald Trump is pressuring Turkey...
...to stop its offensive in northern Syria...
...with calls for a ceasefire and sanctions against Turkish officials,...
...as he plans to send a delegation led by Vice President Mike Pence to Ankara.
In France, police used water cannons against protesting firemen..
...in front of the French National Assembly...
...on the margins of a national demonstration over their working conditions.
South Africa's embattled former president, Jacob Zuma,...
...will appeal a court ruling that he face trial on corruption charges over a 1990s arms deal.
Zuma's last-minute appeal will delay the case.
Civil defense members spray water on the burning trees of the Chouf District...
...as Lebanon turns to its neighbors for help with battling the forest fires...
...that have ravaged homes and killed a volunteer firefighter in the Mediterranean country.
Finally, from the US, final preparations are under way in Westerville, Ohio,...
...where 12 Democratic presidential candidates will square off in the first debate...
...since the opening of the impeachment inquiry into Republican President Donald Trump.